I think prisons should be austere I
think they should involve a lot of hard
work and I think that they should be
full of the power of the state the
problem with prisons is that they're
tough in the wrong way uh they're not
austere they're squalid they're chaotic
despite the efforts of the hugely
outnumbered prison officers whose whose
role in this is so often completely
underestimated and who and who keep
things from becoming totally uncivilized
in a way which ought to be more valued
but they are chaotic they are
increasingly under the control of the
inmates they're full of drugs and
they're full of suicide and they're full
of completely uncontrolled violence and
therefore there is no in the place where
the law sends people there is no rule of
law in fact there is no rule of
authority and so they're completely
unfit for the job they're supposed to do